we're on the road in the monkey bus
driving at a leisurely pace that's the
only way we even have a chance of
spotting wild Barbary macaques Welsh
woman Shan waters and her team have been
observing the lives of these threatened
primates for several years especially in
the reef mountains in northern Morocco a
research project going on there that
looks particularly at the wild macaques
behavior so the macaques have been
habituated specifically for that
research here for example they are not
habituated to people at all they're
afraid of people and so when they see
people they rent so it's impossible to
follow them the habitat of the Barbary
macaques is under threat deforestation
is taking place in the reef mountains to
clear the way for farmland bush and
forest is being affected too as a new
study shows where we are it still looks
intact
Shawn waters tells us the macaques can
live relatively well here so there's
hope of spotting some we've been
traveling with the Wildlife
conservationists for four days now this
is a small committed team of under 10
people how much it one is one of them he
gets closest to the shy Barbary macaques
he often spends time here alone to
observe them he knows the forest inside
out he spent days and nights here and
knows the places the macaques frequent
they live in groups that usually consist
of 40 to 60 animals the hard to spot
among the leaves and rocks who Makita
the macaques come along with me so I'm
never afraid at night in the morning I
find them in front of me again the same
thing in the evening till they go to
sleep we protect each other like friends
for a long time Shepherds in the bush
and forests were no
friends of the monkeys they hunted them
sometimes to sell them but a number of
shepherds have been persuaded to stop
often it's usually only their dogs that
still hunt the monkeys Eunice is one
such shepherd he stresses that his dogs
are well behaved and just watch over his
flocks but he says that free-roaming
animals do sometimes attack the macaques
and kill them the next day the weather's
so ugly it's pointless to look for
Barbary macaques so we visit the
building the Wildlife conservationists
plan to expand into an education and
conservation centre inside Sean shows us
photographs documenting the illegal
trade in Barbary macaques we have a
problem with the animals being caught
and captured from the middle atlas for
the illegal pet trade and also what
happens is that some of them are caught
and used as photo props we already work
the forestry authorities to confiscate
illegally hell macaques some of those
animals we you we look at very carefully
to see if they can be released back into
the wild
so if we could have some kind of
building here a very basic structure
where we could assess their behavior and
their suitability for release that would
make life a lot easier for us because at
the moment we don't have that we're in
the village of Tahlia mean a group of
women has gathered around al Fidel Harod
he's especially good at getting the
villagers to understand the macaques he
supervises a touring exhibition that
informs people about the threat to the
monkeys when they find a monkey at a
site for instance they phone as quickly
sometimes 20 different people we've
confiscated quite a number
of animals simply because the exhibition
has been so informative
Talya mean is a remote village in the
bush and forest it's only been reachable
by a dirt road for the last year and a
half time seems almost to have stood
still here but the village is slowly
changing there's now a small Center
where women can learn reading and
arithmetic for instance or knitting and
sewing protecting the macaques is not a
priority here so Shawn waters proceeds
carefully she makes it clear that the
villagers needs will be taken into
account animal in politics thinks yawn
she not only explains why her team wants
to protect the macaques but also how it
will benefit the residents of Tahlia
mean Ozma translates we need to
understand how the people who share the
macaques habit overuse the forest see
them attacks because they don't
necessarily see them within trip as the
same way as we do in in from Europe from
Europe so for example they might not see
them as interesting or beautiful in
themselves they may see them as an
economic resource or a pest
for example we still haven't given up
hope of spotting wild Barbary macaques
the next day we start off again
Shawn they ditch okay come on Alistar we
meet Mohammed who as so often is walking
alone through the forest he tells us
he's seen two groups one more nervous
than the other we try to find the calmer
group and we're in luck
20 to 30 meters away from us we discover
one macaque after another and we keep
our distance so as not to scare them
away studies have shown that wild
Barbary macaques are healthier and
better able to reproduce than those that
are accustomed to humans so we don't
stay for too long